what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
fresh and fit's um copyright situation
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos okay so
for people that have not
followed
okay i'm gonna do like a brief this is
the fresh and fit show so this is they
do these like live streams every day
and
brush and fit
have been in a couple controversies the
last couple of months
um
abba and preach
have made a bunch of videos about them
over these controversies
and so did everyone in the manosphere
which is like the sector of youtube rim
so fresh and fit decided
that they
were going to
copyright strike people let me know
what's up let me find the actual video
i'm gonna actually go to
abba and preach his page right how are
you giving people business now you may
or may not know what a copyright strike
is but basically when you copyright
strike someone
um
you're saying that they used your
content like illegally pretty much
um okay so this is
i was kevin was for some of the comments
okay
let's start from the beginning fresh and
fit decided to hit us with
dozens of copyright claims
we saw this was probably going to end up
coming and uh honestly not upset about
it at all they apologized to us for some
of the comments that they made in
regards to preach significant other and
then afterwards today recently they
decided to copyright claim the video
that we did in response to their apology
so
so imagine being like yo you know we
[ __ ] up we take accountability we're
sorry okay yeah we're like oh this is
how we feel about your apology copyright
claim
so we received all the claims as you
guys can go look through our youtube
videos the videos are still there and
we'll get to why that is later they feel
like they're in the right doing so i'm
going to play a clip from their channel
which again they might copyright claim
but i'm still going to play it so you
guys can get the full context because i
could explain it myself
but
i don't want to
yeah bro you know what i'm saying like
we're back you know what i'm saying the
haters tried to kill us over 30 plus
youtube channels made videos like
slandering our name whatever it is okay
so this is so he's saying slander so
that's a very specific allegation so
he's saying
what you guys said was not true
now they're mad that they're get there's
consequences actions bruh y'all are not
going to be able to run around and drag
her name in the mud with you know
falsely without some kind of recourse
bro okay so falsely that that is that is
the key there it's just not the way the
world works i just and just because your
your reality is ours doesn't mean that
we're wrong like we live this lifestyle
this is who we are yeah so okay just
that sounds like something a girl would
say just because
your reality isn't ours
like doesn't mean we're wrong
you guys know if you heard a girl say
that
you would be mad
like no it's either true or it's not
true
hey man you know what it is bro someone
mad that they can't do what we do that's
what it really is man yeah facts you
know what i'm saying
and i don't even want it to our own horn
but think about it so that's that's
number two number two is
are the people talking bad about them
jealous
bro monday we talk to you guys about
making money right we brought
grant cardone robert kiyosaki you know
what i'm saying critically acclaimed
authors guys that are multi-millionaires
billionaires on the show teach you how
to make money wednesdays we talk about
dating right you know what kills me
about these guys they always talk about
yeah we're making men's lives so much
better our channels about doing all this
stuff if you go look at the views on
their videos
none of them are on the videos where
they're supposedly helping men none of
the men are tuning in for financial
advice the men are not tuning in for
facebook
to me that's irrelevant because
it
i think probably from there from fresh
and fit's point of view
they
they believe that if they're helping one
guy that's enough for them um
so that i don't
i don't think that's a problem let me
keep going
and it's okay
it's okay but it's a bit of a lie
that's like saying so then then so i'm
gonna go a little forward
so this is fresh and or avant preach
showing fresh and fit videos where they
have used other people's content yeah
here we are to kick off the hood
olympics 2021 so uh let's continue on
getting up easily from that finally
found it i was with fresh talking about
some other stuff and this talks about
public transportation this scene right
here comes okay so
from the first game that they play which
is red light green light we all know
this game we're gonna play uh some
uh clips i guess here from inside clips
this guy but it seems like based on what
fresh and fit said which they
specifically said slander
okay
now that's an allegation
and there's a million channels i could
pull the slander claims from but i'm
gonna go back
to
from preach fresh and fit
one of the videos from this summer
okay so there was a couple allegations
between
fresh and fit and abba and preach
one of them was
basically they sell dating advice
and
fresh had a girl that was his alleged
sugar baby he met her on a sugar site
and
it it kind of makes you question their
credibility because if you're on a sugar
site
do you really have this like game you're
selling you know
or is it just
okay is it just like your money and your
status
um okay fresh and fit the emperor hair
has no clothes
the fresh and fit are capping hard
okay let's do the emperor has no clothes
you don't
okay
are better than you [ __ ] today this
topic all right seems like the guys from
fresher fit are really upset
we
are better than you [ __ ] period be one
this mindset
i'm telling you it looks so trashy
anybody that grew up in like a family
that had any
sense of like class
that behavior is so classy if you're
better than someone you don't have to
say it
that's why kevin samuels walks around
with the confidence he has and why he
doesn't entertain any of the people that
talk about about him because he knows he
has the most power and influence of
anyone in the manosphere anyone
um
entertainment
it all depends
want to know our thoughts i'm going to
keep it really brief all right
i don't have much thoughts on their
platform are they doing some good things
for some people i'm sure i'm no doubt
i'm not even denigrating that we just
came at them for their ideas with
regards to
paying for bucks
and all this stuff thought it was full
of [ __ ] i'm like yo
real last [ __ ]
even more what i find really distasteful
is you come to find out that myron gains
himself right the so-called pickup
artist the master has his own seeking
arrangements account his own profile all
right this is on the web you can find it
this man's out here talking about don't
pay for box don't pay for box he's on a
website for sugar daddies and sugar
okay
so is this untrue
right there not untrue
babies okay
all right you want to be a giant
hypocrite do your thing okay then you
come to find out this man is talking
about
listen if you we want we want burning
desire from ladies ain't that what they
say
right you want to get their best so you
got to earn it
come to find out this man's telling
girls in the dms that if they want to
come on the platform they have to
[ __ ] if they don't he gets upset
about it he gets all pissy
okay is this true
because he's claiming slander now the
question is is this true
this is a screenshot of him
saying i'm not collaborating you have
f'ed a bunch of dudes i know and aren't
special
um i saw the full text exchange and to
be honest russian fit has so much
content it's very hard to find these
specific time stamps
um
but when i saw this full exchange it
didn't really change my opinion on the
situation
um
but i'm going to keep going
oh you [ __ ] all my other boys you
won't [ __ ] me then you can't get on the
platform so wait you want to bang a girl
who just wants to come on the platform
for clout and you so that goes again
against their credibility as dating
coaches
like if you are
if i sold you guys
a dating course which i don't but if i
did i might someday i would totally
expect you to come at my credibility
because if i'm selling something that is
saying that i'm credible enough to sell
you that
and i i did a collab with torsha and she
was saying why is it our problem that
other people are wasting their money
basically i i think she didn't say they
were wasting their money but she was
saying like that that's the specific
specific argument and what i would say
is it's not
but
you have a right
to criticize someone selling a course
and if you put yourself if you choose to
put yourself on a public platform
you can't be mad when criticism comes
i've been canceled before
like [ __ ] happens i think that's burning
desire
and again guys i don't even care that he
does goes about that way to bang girls
do whatever you want you earned your
platform go ahead meets the hypocrisy of
these ideas you preach to these men that
they have to always seek this thing that
this is the way to live that this is the
best way but you don't even want to talk
that's what i find distasteful it's like
derek jackson talking about be faithful
your wife don't pay for box come to find
out this man is cheating on everyone how
are you any different can you tell me
now everyone's gonna get whoa you know
we're attacking people and demands i
don't care about them atmosphere i don't
care about none of this move with
integrity in life that's it i'm not
hearing about it some scene
oh you can't go on this party i don't
care at the end of the day the truth
remains the truth when i came into the
game when i was listening to patrice we
didn't call it red pen we just called it
the truth these [ __ ] is front and on
some points that doesn't mean they're
not helpful to you maybe if you're one
of their fans right maybe they help you
with finances my fitness maybe even they
helped you with game i don't know but
all we talked about were these ideas and
how they were hypocritical right and
that's the interesting thing about the
manosphere is they talk about how
emotional women are
but
they they react emotionally all the time
on this podcast and that's okay i mean
everyone's emotional to some extent
but
it's just a little bit interesting
here's the thing you guys been blowing
us up man yeah yeah you guys you guys
have been blowing us up with diamonds
apparently uh auburn priest decided to
make a video
uh talking smack out of nowhere out of
left field and it's funny about capping
and paying for bucks and i was like did
we talk about this several months ago
like why are you guys bringing this up
like now like what the hell we're
trending man why are you bringing this
up and then it's because they're
trending so apparently it's
the jealousy i think that's what they're
getting at yeah the only reason we
brought it up later was good it would
guys it would make sense if you're
trending you have more videos for people
to criticize obviously you're gonna get
more criticism the bigger you get that's
to me common sense we already covered a
couple of videos from that podcast and
the second one after and this we did
both podcasts on the same day the first
one and then i did came back later on
for the second one i completely forgot
about the first one so i covered the
second one and then months later
somebody sent me a link to it's like hey
what did you think about this
conversation so i rewatched it i'm like
hey man there's a lot of dumb things
that were said let me cover it it's not
that deep okay this whole idea that
there's some giant conspiracy it's not
that deep but anyways and then the
second question i would have is how
would you dictate if someone is jealous
of you
versus they're just doing it because
they disagree with you because for me
that shouldn't be a point at all
you will never know why someone is doing
something so all you can do is look at
their actions
if if allah and if abba and preach
had a thousand subscribers would it be
jealousy then
if they were growing at the same rate
that fresh and fit were growing at the
time would it be jealousy then
what dictates jealousy
because it seems like
if a creator that's much much bigger
than you is criticizing you they would
take jealousy off the table but they
don't
and so then the next argument is oh well
we grow faster we have nicer things we i
have this car
i bought this car i have this watch i
have this this and this
we live a lifestyle you'll never live
and it's interesting
because if abba and preach wanted that
lifestyle
i would be surprised if they couldn't
afford it with that many subscribers and
how many views their video
videos do i'm not an expert at how much
money you make off of youtube
or am i maybe i am
it doesn't matter but you guys
understand what i'm saying
so
one it doesn't matter if they're jealous
or not that the art you focus on the
argument not people's intentions because
look at you you could spend all day
going back and forth about people's
intentions if you guys wanted to know
that was why we're trending man yeah
we're popping right now but then i did
as always men like women like numbers
don't right and then i thought to myself
why would they bring this up now uh
chris can you show exhibit a real fast
so let's see here uh they got let's see
these guys have almost a million more
subs than us guys all right so we're the
blue line we're the blue line they're
the red they have 1.38 which is one one
million three hundred eighty thousand
subscribers guys we only have 430 000
subscribers okay we have
so my question to myron would be if they
grew at a faster weight rate would it
still be jealousy
and
i don't actually know this because i
don't i don't know how to pull up this
chart but are they growing at a faster
rate now
it would seem like it their videos have
popped up a lot more than russian fits
have on my
home page really like one less than one
third of their joint right and we got 20
million
1.38 that was a couple months ago
um
so they have 200 000 more subscribers
now
than then
and
how many subscribers did they have
um i think they're at about 500 000
does it say how many subscribers they
have
in this video
i can't see but
okay and they got 14.9 million views
very interesting for you guys to go
ahead and make a video insulting us
months after the fact i wonder why oh
it's because we're hotter than you guys
right now i'll just talk about we make
so much money we're getting all these
views these guys are clout chasing it's
trashy guys i grew up in a one percent
family
i'm telling you i know
i know wealthy people
and they do not carry themselves like
this
they they don't they do not flash it in
your face um there's maybe a small
select few that do
sure i'm sure they exist but it is not
common
ruff when i came on your podcast your
podcast was far smaller i didn't care
that you guys were a smaller podcast i
was like cool you guys seem to do some
interesting content i'll just jump on
i'm not the type of [ __ ] who looks at
people and judges their value or their
uh perception of me based off of how
many followers they have or how many
views they get we cover people who are
far larger than us and who have way
bigger platforms and we cover people
with a hundred subscribers we don't come
at people based off of the size the
following they have we talk about ideas
if you think back about the video when
we said all that stuff about boxing this
it was on the topics we talked about
fresh's past we didn't talk about him
faking press releases we didn't talk
about you paying for box we didn't talk
about none of that [ __ ] you guys are
getting so hyper emotional about this
thing it's funny to me for so-called
alpha males you guys don't seem to have
any control over your temper
our channel is better than yours we get
more views than you we've been on less
than you we work harder than y'all
[ __ ] we cut our hair more than you
[ __ ] like yo if y'all
well the haircut
oh no the ladies must come running with
the haircut
not the haircut i'm sorry
okay
like if y'all really really wanted three
this [ __ ] preacher's married prior to a
[ __ ] beluga whale somewhere and yeah
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] and how do you think
it's our 40 years old yo yo oh last
nigga's too bro yo bruh
i wasn't gonna do this wait the the hand
symbol yo i was not gonna [ __ ] do
this
but y'all got me hyped now okay
yo
i know you guys are not talking bro
my man abba looks like he got off a
camel hasn't cut his hair in years
dusty as [ __ ]
no
bruh and this is suddenly roasted on you
right now bro somalia you know i was
like yo what enemy you came from bro now
[ __ ] looking bummy as hell bro i'm on
you right okay so it's interesting this
is so interesting because
their argument now is that people were
coming for them and all this stuff
um
but like what is this
sir
sir
but he did specifically say slander
or liable i forget but he it was his
allegation was that people are saying
things that are false and so far in this
video i have not seen anything that is
false i'm not gonna [ __ ] because
obviously i'm saying that's a style i
call it we're better than you [ __ ] we
make more money than you [ __ ] we got a
better [ __ ] channel then y'all [ __ ]
we get more views than y'all [ __ ] the
only thing you guys got on us is now you
guys been on longer but i dare [ __ ]
too
next year this time we're gonna lap you
[ __ ] because you wait wait
[Laughter]
wait what what was the date on this
video
august 17th
august september october november
december four months
so you got you got seven left
let me let me know
you know what nobody works harder than
us no period we make more money and
that's the worst part is that i like i
like to see i love to see a black man
get paid
get your money i've never that's your
money if your views are stupid your
views are stupid but if you're getting
paid get your money
yeah that's not what i'm here for
there's not a single person that could
ever say that we've ever
feigned jealousy or gotten mad about
other people succeeding we move at our
own pace yeah we've been on the platform
along with you congratulations to me
it's not even that deep you guys are
doing well for yourselves good for you
crazy i ain't never been mad at [ __ ]
making money this is about the idea so
all this talk about clout and all this
that you guys have lived in so i'm gonna
do this whole video and the only reason
i know there's a lot of controversy now
i know there's a lot of controversy now
with using other people's video and the
only reason i'm using this whole video
is because
i want to see if they say anything
untrue and i'm assuming i would be
shocked if they did not copyright this
video so myron's claim is
they people are saying things that are
untrue
and this would be a video that he
alleged
lee allegedly said something untrue
so i i haven't seen anything yet but let
me know in the comments me so long and
you've been faking your lifestyle for so
long that you think everybody is chasing
clout that everybody wants to be with an
instagram baddie your whole platform is
based around clout chasers so that's why
your mind is warped miami's [ __ ] up
that's why the girls you bring on
everyone's like yo who are these dumb
broads that you bring on right because
they're all cloud chasers so you guys
mindset is all warped and [ __ ] it's not
like that everywhere around the world
not everyone is about clout if we were
about clout do you think we'd be
covering things like this pandemic and
all these other issues that [ __ ]
derank our youtube channel it's not
about clout at the end of the day it's
always about integrity that's it for us
it's about integrity whether we win or
we lose money got dumbass [ __ ] with
the same tired background same [ __ ]
million plaque we got two hundred
thousand dollar plaques now and we're
going to get a million ply and we're
gonna get the other channel another two
million as well and fresher's channel
gonna hit 100 000 bucks
okay and this is why i think men they
have this attitude where they're like
everyone wants to see us fail
okay
people do not want to see nice people
that work hard fail that are like kind
and respectful
but
when you when you act like this that's
why people want to see you fail
sorry
are better than you [ __ ] period [ __ ]
out of here man and we don't pay for
bucks
these are kind of like
okay wouldn't that be untrue because
i swear fresh has said he used to pay
for box you know what it's like you know
it's like you know i love it that these
guys call themselves alph and all this
other stuff it makes me laugh because
they got such [ __ ] energy is crazy yeah
it's like when you're talking to a girl
about a topic yeah yeah you know you're
talking you've seen this before you know
you're talking to a girl about a topic
and you guys having a discussion and
she's losing the argument all of a
sudden she starts bringing up your dick
is small
what does that have to do with economics
it's like
they do the same thing i find it so
funny that these guys like think they're
alpha and one percent men and all this
other stuff right they lack integrity
they get upset at the most random stuff
when i was on the podcast and they
kicked out that girl one of the girls
beside was like yo you're being
emotional no i'm not being emotional i
was like bro like why are you screaming
like this no wonder these girls come on
your podcast and don't respect you you
don't command respect you just yell and
get them kicked out you think that's
alpha behavior
okay is any of that untrue
let me know in the comments is it untrue
the idea that you can't even get respect
from these ladies
is an indication of the fact that you
don't know what you're doing it's
hyper-emotional you're just screaming
and getting mad
i'm laughing at this because it's
pathetic
i don't know what's wrong but every
episode i see you just screaming get mad
screaming at ladies railroading like
women who aren't prepared with all these
stats and numbers that these ladies are
like oh you want to come on a podcast
like sure uh turns out that eight
percent of all men
well how does that have a way to have a
discussion okay one thing that i will
say is when i was on the show
they do not tell you the topics
beforehand and i asked what the topic
would be and the
manager producer guy he responded
something very vague and does not give
you specifics
so it's very hard to come off prepared
when
you're coming on to a podcast and
you know they don't tell you what you're
talking about
just chill [ __ ] it's not that deep
also second point when i was on the
podcast i asked
fresh not myra and after i said
is it okay if i post any clips from the
podcast on my channel and he said yes i
didn't receive a copyright strike so i
don't know
if one i'm just not big enough for them
to care or two
they
they like you know stayed to that but
when i was on i asked if i could use it
and i actually didn't use as many clips
as i wanted to because my manager said
since i didn't get it in writing it's
not a good idea it's not worth it i'm
like yo real last [ __ ]
here's the other thing too these guys
say realize [ __ ] don't play the box
and one's on seeking arrangements the
other one
the other one is lying about
having three girls at one time shut the
[ __ ] the other one you know what the
[ __ ] okay
slander
is that true or untrue
the three girls in one night story that
every so if you don't know
fresh said that it was a very outlandish
story that just did not seem true
basically
and i'm i'm going to be butchering this
because i don't care enough to look it
up basically fresh said
that
he
had a threesome or had this nba player
offer him
girls and said he could pick any girl
and have sex with her in this random
room and like benny had three in a row
or something
i don't know some crazy story and
everyone in the manosphere said cap we
don't believe you
i don't i'd have to have like a
different content creator that knows
more about legality but i don't think
it doesn't seem like
saying i don't believe you on a topic
would qualify as slander you know what
kills me about fresh like if you listen
to him you know he has an okay it's it's
painfully obvious that this man like
even when you go watch the the the the
vlogs that he does he's like he has this
whole thing don't lead with money and
like in his bunch of his videos he's
like hey girl i'm gonna shower you with
gifts come on we're gonna go shop for
lambos and ferraris i'm like bruh if it
wasn't for your clout you wouldn't be
out here getting anything let's be real
so i find it so funny as i talk about
paying for bucks you want to know why
this [ __ ] doesn't want to pay for a box
this is his experience he went to
colombia with his [ __ ] okay
they went to a brothel
he saw a bad woman and he's like oh wow
she's like come upstairs with me he
didn't know it was a whorehouse because
this [ __ ] so lacking self-awareness you
know he thinks everyone respects him
[ __ ] goober okay he gets in and she's
like 20 he's like you want me to pay
[ __ ] you don't know a whorehouse when
you walk into one where were you raised
do you not
i don't know how you could be a pickup
artist and lack this much self-awareness
so he said
i paid the 20
i banged her and i felt disgusting
afterwards
and that's why i'll never pay for bucks
ruff
if the first time you eat out is
mcdonald's burger and you say you hate
all restaurants after that's not a
problem with restaurant restaurants or
that's a problem with you promise your
choices
here's the thing the truth about this
whole escorting and paying for bucks
ceos nba players princes all them they
all pay for bucks they pay for high-end
escorts why discretion
expertise
okay i don't care how much your girl
loves you and all that other stuff if
she hasn't studied sex if she hasn't
done all that [ __ ] if she hasn't taken
the time to really learn
she's not as good as other people this
whole idea of like if she have
enthusiasm [ __ ] you ever been with a
girl that's really into you and she's
using her teeth on your blow jobs she
got all the enthusiasm in the world it's
never going to be a substitute for
technique the only [ __ ] who are this
dumb ornan who not had a lot of sex or
men who never paid for good bucks
okay
none of that's untrue i mean it's an
opinion right but that's not untrue even
kevin samuels will come in and say i'll
pay for box i pay for women to come with
me cause he's a real [ __ ] patrice
o'neil pays for box the highest [ __ ]
in the game they pay for box not all the
time but sometimes it's convenient
so you want me to tell you that you're
working at your middle class job you
know more about what's being alpha and
all this then the ceos the most famous
and rich people in the world okay so
yeah their [ __ ] is beta because they
pay for a box but you right working at
the company as a minimum wage worker for
their company you think you know more
about what it means to be alpha
get them out of here just don't pay for
box say it's not for you it's not for
everyone it's okay but paying 100 for a
hooker and then saying it's not as good
as a random girl i met on the street
probably not
you paid for [ __ ] sometimes you get [ __ ]
service you pay well you get better
service it's not complicated
these guys talk like they're
knowledgeable about this stuff and the
very people they admire pay for box
go have this conversation with kevin
then go go have this conversation with
real [ __ ] go ahead with the nba
players the same nba player that made
you uh bang three girls in one night
okay
true right nothing
i'm really trying people have said
that
okay
you know that was so stupid about that
this guy man wants me to believe he's at
a pool party okay he was a random pool
he's at a pool party this nba player
comes with him he's like oh oh my god
man do you know where the coolest
parties are here
speeding it up just uh have your
instagram instagram oh man we [ __ ] the
same girl oh my god what was in the same
[ __ ] bro i got a story i got a mansion
party you want to come over and we gonna
get it for the guy hold on so the guy
that was looking for the hottest party
happens to have a mansion party next get
the [ __ ] out of here with your boat your
ass so he needed your help to find a
party in town but he got a manchester
party with 50 girls are rolling through
and let me ask you bro let me ask you in
this made up scenario where you're
capping the [ __ ] out of possibilities
you want me to believe that this man had
50 girls and none of them were paid hmm
do you think that these girls that you
banged there supposedly that you had all
three but you didn't want to threesome
because you wanted to go one at a time
because you're too awkward enough you
want me to believe that these girls had
burning desire for you of course not
they wanted to [ __ ] the nba player best
they didn't want to get around with you
but okay is that untrue
i mean
it's clearly speculation
but that doesn't seem like it would hold
up as qui in court as slander do you
think none of these girls have hate they
pay for box all these guys these high
value man they'll pay for bucks
so
man listen you guys press whatever
follow okay that's that's it um
because they're just gonna yeah
so
then
so if anyone doesn't know the next thing
i decided to do was look at copyright
because i'm going to be honest when i
first started the channel i probably did
a decent amount of videos where i wasn't
talking enough for it to be
a reaction video when you first start on
youtube you don't really know the ins
and outs of things and a lot of it is
just
you know running around with the chicken
like like a chicken with this head cut
off trying to figure it out
and it's actually this conversation has
been very helpful because a lot of the
things that i've learned i'm really
going to use in my channel moving
forward because i can look at
a couple videos i've done and think
maybe i should have talked more added
more of my original content and less
reaction
so
let me find i was googling these are
notes i had for this
for
copyright and i
basically googled
the copyright law and i just put the
notes i put into a google doc
now okay if the reaction video uses the
original work as a foil to create
something new
as the case in most videos
at issues in equal three then a finding
of fair use is probable because latter
videos
cater to a different audience than the
original requires creative effort
on part of the content creator so what
the that was talking about was i was
talking about a case very similar to
this where
um
a reaction video was
was talking about
i don't know how to describe it like the
the original guy basically like they was
talking bad about someone and the
conclusion that the courts have drawn
when it comes to copyright is it has to
say something different than the
original work so you cannot
basically watch the video a fresh and
fit video and say everything myron says
say the same thing like it has to be its
own piece of content and its own piece
of work does that make sense
um
okay so
oh wait this is the wrong tab
um
so you have to
fair use
so in conclusion
it continues the k to be the case that
no single factor is
dis positive of the fair use analysis of
these three factors it is clear that
crucial injury
inquiry with regard to reaction videos
is the extent to which the video is
transformative as the court inclined
noted videos within this genre
vary widely in terms of purpose
structure and the extent to which they
rely on the potentially copyrighted
material
um accordingly while
in oh my god i cannot read i hate big
words
inter-spearing short segments of an
original work with criticism commentary
or jokes directed at that may qualify as
fair use as with the case of
okay some case i don't know about
reaction videos that were merely to
a group viewing session without
commentary might not qualify so you have
to have your own qual
commentary and it has to be an original
piece of work
so
then okay so fresh and fit hits all
these channels with copyright strikes
and they claim that it is slander okay
fair enough
the video that i watched i did not see
anything untrue but then fresh infit
says this is their response
over here on the phone
i gotta turn off the speed
just like that um and anything else
chris that i missed no we're good oh my
gosh am i gonna get copyright struck
please don't oh my gosh i'd be so
irritated
they're going on tick tock fresher 15th
it's on tt which we might get cancelled
off that soon
special mention yeah we're also going to
get cancelled off youtube allegedly as
well so uh
[Music]
i don't know how you know that's going
to eat me never gone
the bunch of hoes would be like yo it
was fun last year yo but let me just
address this real quick guys we're not
going anywhere there's no seven days
there's none of this stuff you know what
i'm saying our uh you know
um we didn't get anything for from
youtube right this way oh you've been
notified like no bro our our lawyers are
already handled it you know what i'm
saying and uh you know very successful
in removing some videos guys you know it
is what it is you know we're not here to
try to go after anybody we got to
protect ourselves man and it's crazy how
everyone's trying to jump on us for
for protecting yourself but you said
from slander
all right now the question is are they
trying to protect themselves from
criticism
and the way this looks
from my perspective it looks like they
are because
the the video that i showed you
they haven't preached didn't say
anything that was untrue
they just said words they don't like
protecting ourselves after all the crazy
allegations that were made that were
proven not true so i mean if you guys
are going to come okay were they proven
untrue
i'm sure there's a million allegations
against them i'm sure one or two maybe
wasn't true i don't know i haven't
followed the ins and outs of it but
guys
if it's criticism you can't i mean you
can't you can certainly do what you want
but it gives you a bad look
and it comes off as very emotional
and like whining basically
don't
come at us for defending ourselves and
um okay all right that's fine that's
what it is we're here to make contact
we're not here to stir drama or talk
negatively about those people we got to
protect ourselves but no like we're here
to make content if you don't like it bro
don't watch it yeah you don't have to
watch it so
y'all can like just literally click the
x on the top right be like [ __ ] these
[ __ ] and go watch somebody else it's
kind it's fine man you have the ability
to not watch us you don't have to watch
us bro i don't understand i won't be
straight talking about us okay but this
is what you have to understand we we
make content for our audiences
so our audience asks us to watch certain
videos and react to them and give our
commentary that's what reaction channels
do
look i do not got time to run a whole
show with a bunch of female sorry
i'm a
semi-pro volleyball player i'm in
getting my masters i
i do not have time like somebody i'm not
watching
none of your [ __ ] like i don't get it
the intro the ending none of it yeah
that's the second point you don't have
to watch us
okay
so if the second point if you disagree
with us don't watch us
okay something doesn't have intros
some do
so uh but no anyway man with that said
guys um you know we're here to make
content man we're here to help you guys
with making money getting girls getting
in shape etc we're the number one men's
podcast for the reason big guests coming
next week yes man yo the train will not
stop guys the train will not stop we're
gonna keep going and i'll tell you guys
this too man a big motivator for me
every day i get messages from guys
saying hey man
i was gonna off myself or i was gonna do
this or whatever and this video on part
two that's fine i i agree with
you know
making your channel working hard that's
fine
um
okay so i think that's pretty much let
me make sure i take notes before every
video sorry if i'm exposing myself
um if someone is selling a course do we
have the right to question their
validity oh this is another point i was
going to talk about so
let me put you guys a little higher
okay
i believe that if you are selling a
course people have a right to
ask the question are you valid
so
oh i talked about that earlier do you
have the right to criticize a public
figure i will say i do think you have
the right to criticize a public figure
but there are certain like low blows we
should avoid
um like don't go after someone for their
appearance and stuff they can't change
like if they have a disability their
race like
i mean i think you're allowed to like
legally but
um and then
there are three things that brush and
fit really came under fire for
and the question is do they fall under
libel or slander
shoot sorry guys
um
if so what said was untrue let me know
in the comments um i haven't seen
anything at least in that specific video
that was untrue but let me know if
there's something i missed and i will
react to it later don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time